[Musique]
itunes c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
sourit
[Musique]
duchesse
c
[Musique]
c'est
c'est pas toujours facile de trouver un
atelier qui accepte de réparer des
valenciens parce que les ateliers les
boutiques de vélo aujourd'hui sont
concentrés sur leur gamme neuves est
sûre sur le service après vente de ses
gammes là mais après ça va être
compliqué pour eux de trouver des pièces
structurelles anciennes et ça c'est tout
un travail qu'il faut faire en amont moi
j'ai les pièces pour
[Musique]
je veux
cass
[Musique]
à
ouais et
sauvé l'honneur dans quel état j'étais
changer les battants de frein
la muse de changer d'air ici les liens
ça peut arriver
ouais merci comme neuf pas
[Musique]
non en fait
[Applaudissements]
pour ne pas avoir en racheter un nouveau
parce qu'il était comment cette
dangereuse des choses qui n'allaient
plus eu et puis et puis deuxièmement en
plus c'est une formule à celle
économique puisque livre il permet de
remettre en état un vélo à un prix comme
assez raisonnable
[Musique]
tu veux